what is the best thing about Bernie
Sanders well the best thing about Bernie
Sanders is that he's 78 years old he has
nothing to lose absolutely nothing to
lose so he can say whatever he wants
he's not beholden to anyone if he has an
idea that he thinks is good he can say
it and because he's a senator and he's
running for president people are going
to pay attention college tuition for all
for free paid for by the government yeah
it's now something that Hillary Clinton
has to respond to mm-hmm you know and
and if you're progressive and you're
looking for someone to keep Hillary
Clinton on her toes in a way that
actually keeps her on our toes and and
isn't kind of too careful about it like
martin O'Malley you might want to be a
vice president who might want to
preserve his political future Bernie
Sanders doesn't care about Democratic
donors doesn't have to kiss him but you
can say whatever he wants and that's
very refreshing I think it's the best
thing about it yes so in a way isn't
Bernie Sanders the running the best
thing that could have happened to the
Democrats because if for nothing else
he'll do what you're saying no force
Hillary to become a better candidate and
to differentiate herself from the
Republicans which everyone right now is
saying well there's actually not that
much difference from her and a lot of
the Republicans but yeah Bernie Bernie's
pulling her a little bit and she's gonna
have to address him you know I think
that but her reaction probably when she
heard in the news that Sanders was gonna
run was oh I can deal with that I want
to be great I'm sure but we have good
conversations in the green room before
debates you know yeah what do you think
so 78 years old you know he's I think
born in Brooklyn he's an avowed
socialist right he calls himself a
socialist what do you make of the word
socialist now because people were
calling Obama a socialist the first time
he ran they still call him Drudge
they're still calling him a socialist
all the time
but the idea that you know seven years
ago if you call someone a socialist it
was the worst thing you could possibly
say about them and now it's like at
least in a lot of circles that I see
like it's kind of cool oh the socialist
is running like oh it's kind of cool
people are our age younger we don't
really have the same connotation
attached to that word as older people do
but they attach it to communism the
evils of Stalin Marxist Leninist
we don't really have that yeah you know
I mean maybe we can see european-style
democracy and but and that's not a good
but I think most most Americans don't
really have at least the most voting
Americans the younger generation
they just doesn't have that that the
negative energy attached to that
particular that particular word and you
know it's I it's kind of quaint I mean
it's it's it's not gonna not gonna help
him
if he manages to win the primary but
right that's where it becomes a problem
but but I don't think I mean it I don't
think Republicans will be able to use
the fact that a socialist is running to
hurt the Democrats